all right welcome to hannity the very
first presidential debate is now
officially in the books and the
extremely weak the frail the confused
kind of angry joe biden just got
steamrolled by president trump
joe flattout refused to answer simple
basic fundamental questions
unable to respond to the president's
beatdowns and he appeared
flustered irritated and uh well cranky
joe maybe he's past his bedtime probably
stayed up too late needs his nap
anyway we have a lot of live reaction
for the full hour analysis moments away
donald trump jr will be here sarah
sanders will be here
dan bongino judge uh janine will also
join us ari fleischer
uh will join us as well but first let's
start with joe biden who once again
refused to answer a simple basic
fundamental question
would he support packing the united
states supreme court
he refuses to answer take a look are you
willing to tell the american people
tonight
whether or not you will support either
ending the filibuster
or packing the court whatever position i
take in that that'll become the issue
the issue is the american people should
speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong you feel
let vote now make sure you in fact
let people know he doesn't we're a
senator i'm not going to answer the
question because you answered that
because the question is
the question is radical left will you
listen who is on your list joe this is
who's on your own right
gentlemen i think this is something
that's unprecedented
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment that
was really a
productive segment wasn't it
shut up joe oh he's running for
president also
uh joe won't answer a pivotal important
question on whether or not he'd plan to
destroy the u.s supreme court with an
illicit practice known as court packing
pretty much of a pathetic simple
question why couldn't he answer
tonight joe wasn't just refusing to
answer basic simple questions at times
he could barely form a sentence
you know many um well struggling moments
take a look
20 the 200 million the 200 000 people
that have died on his watch
there how many of those and have
survived well there's seven million
people that contracted covet
he puts pressure and disagrees with his
own
scientist but you're saying harris is
saying you can't trust the side
well no no you can't trust the scientist
he does she didn't say that you can't
she said the public health experts will
be muzzled
will be suppressed well that's what he's
going to try to do
the way to open businesses is give them
the wherewithal to be able to open
we provided money the kind of i was
asking a story about masks well
mask masks make a big difference
billionaires of ray have
made another 300 billion dollars because
of his
profligate tax proposal and
he only focused on the market you have
19 companies
91 companies federal i mean in the
fortune 500 who don't pay a single penny
in taxes
well here's it with you guys wait a
minute you get the final word
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this
hey let me just say
now it's no wonder that joe did well so
little to improve the country
he's been nearly five decades in the
swamp the sewer that we call washington
d.c as the president pointed out
also numerous times tonight let's take a
look
joe i've done more in in 47 months i've
done more than you've done in 47 years
joe
we've done things that you never even
thought about
now instead of actually helping
americans yep 47 years joe biden was
busy
lining the pockets of his own family in
spite of him denying it
he's wrong that includes zero experience
hunter biden and as we have learned this
week
we got russian oligarchs we got
ukrainian oligarchs we got russian
nationals we got chinese nationals
ukrainian nationals kazakh nationals who
yep
all in business we have wire transfers
millions of dollars
from ukrainian russian oligarchs
shopping sprees courtesy of china
people connected to the communist party
of china and of course the 1.5 billion
dollar deal with the bank of china
but he denied it all not true
trade deficit china with mexico
china ate your lunch joe and no wonder
your son goes in and he
takes out he takes out billions of
dollars
takes out billions of dollars to manage
he makes millions of dollars
and also while we're at it why is it
just out of curiosity
the mayor of moscow's wife gave your son
three and a half million dollars
what did he do to deserve it
will the mob the media will they ever
fact check joe let's see
now tuesday november 3rd that is 34 days
away
so much is at stake for this country joe
biden card-carrying member of the sewer
the swamp
and he has been in washington nearly 50
years with nothing to show for it but uh
growing a bank account for his entire
family now joe
well he's made a deal with the radical
left and in spite of his denial tonight
he did go along with the manifesto of
bolshevik bernie if elected
well he might enter the oval office but
they will be in control that's for sure